so during the super bowl
there was an la county health inspector
she uh shut down this brewery that was
open
for the super bowl they were allowed to
be open by the way because basically
what they were doing is
uh in california you're allowed to sell
drinks to go so they had like you know
they made their own beer and they were
selling the beer to go right
health inspectors showed up on super
bowl which was a big day like apparently
they were just
[ __ ] slammed because it's a super
bowl they were gonna did this on purpose
yeah so here's what happened this is her
she got it shut down now it turns out
by you know it turns out that she was
allowed to have it open
but not only did she get it shut down
and made everybody leave
she danced in enjoyment here's the video
there's no audio here's the video
um so that's her she just sanitized her
hand everybody left
all right gone bye everybody
okay see the foot tapping okay tappity
tap tap
tappity tap tap tap tap tap
clap clap clap and now
we break it down
come on do it you know you want to you
know
there it goes there it goes whoo
break it down baby shut down a
family-owned business on the biggest day
ever
and she's having a little jig about it
do these
what i don't understand right because
like there have been videos like this
before where like
the cops like raided like a weed shop
and then we're like
[ __ ] around in there and stuff oh
yeah do these people not understand that
we live in 2021
just how cheap cameras are and how
everyone has
75 of them in their business yep i mean
i don't know
i i know i can't think of a single
business even like shitty businesses
that don't have
at least one functioning camera aiming
into the place
so uh so what did she think was gonna
happen well here's here's the story
i have the actual story here health
inspector was caught on tape performing
a happy dance after she used her
authority to shut down a los
angeles county area brewery sparking
controversy in an investigation
footage which was shared to twitter
showed the inspector sanitizing her
hands before engaging in a dance routine
following the shutdown of bravery
brewery on super bowl sunday
one of the few days of the year when
pubs and breweries are packed and
serving rounds up around the clock
according to the owner bart avery
the inspector stated that uh she had to
stop all operations despite the fact
that the brewery was only pouring draft
beers to go
which you're allowed to do uh after
giving the order the that left avery
decimated financially
the inspector began to dance unaware
that she was on camera
an l.a county health inspector dances
moments after ordering bravery or close
tweeted local radio host steve gregory
she ended up being wrong ruined uh brave
breweries
super bowl business as it turned out the
inspector's judgment call on brave
brewery was not within the guidelines
and the location could have remained
open
veteran and former pro fighter tim
kennedy express disgust
these government bureaucrats will
celebrate the bankruptcy they will laugh
at us as we struggle
to feed our kids they are they are they
get a paycheck regardless
they lost for control and no bounds uh
this inside
this incident was resulted in public
demand for the woman
who for uh many is the epitome of the
power hungry busybody
karen caricature to be fired why are
these people
so full of hate right like like
you know is it just i don't know man
like even when i'm dealing with somebody
in in like that i may not like per se
or i'm ideologically opposed to i don't
take joy in them having to go home and
tell their wife and kids like
well i'm not paying your tuition this
year like you know what i mean like
we're not
we're gonna have to downsize like i take
no joy in that
why are these people so hateful well
that's the thing is you know
we've watched another calif remember the
one uh the buffalo one
where the guy was like we're not closing
down the cops showed up and like leave
unless you have a warrant [ __ ] leave
and all these health officials all these
health inspectors all
talk to you like hey man you know it's i
don't like doing the same i don't like
doing this anymore
to you bro but i gotta do it because
this comes from you know and then they
start doing the [ __ ] pee wee herman
dance to get off on this
they love it but remember these are
people that in in any other part of life
would never have
any [ __ ] power and now she's doing
the [ __ ] tequila dance
just having a good time and it's like
you're right she's doing the peewee
herman
shoes yeah and everybody borrows the
shoes
and you got to think about it like this
is you know when a brewery obviously
think about it it's like
the super bowl's one of their biggest
days people are always
[ __ ] getting hammered on the superman
and you don't get you don't get that
date back they were wrong right
and they'll tell you oh sorry we were
wrong but you don't get that day back
that day's gone now until next year if
you could survive till next year
living in california um so i mean
they're gonna they don't care none of
these people care is she is anything
gonna happen to her
of course not no of course she might get
promoted
um it's
man i'm telling you these people are
just so [ __ ]
hateful and i don't like even at my
hatiest
i've never gotten that bad like i've
never really truly wished people to be
out in the streets like that
it's really sick